a crosswalk in Germany where you can
play pong against someone across the
street while you wait for the light to
turn green and say hello to the newly
discovered blue butt monkey B sauce
Kevin Harris this is fine
[Music]
new energy calculations suggest warp
drive could scientifically be possible
previous calculations predicted the mass
energy of Jupiter would be necessary to
cause space-time warp around a football
shaped starship with a large flat ring
encircling it but if the ring were
doughnut shaped it may be powered by a
mass the size of a spacecraft like the
Voyager 1 probe launched in 1977
so somebody invent this plays now thanks
scientists and Argonne National
Laboratory recently demonstrated
acoustic levitation they use sound waves
to levitate droplets of solutions
containing different drugs with two
opposing speakers pumping out 22,000
Hertz that trap the droplets in a
standing wave the point is to study
drugs and an amorphous state which is
more desirable than the crystalline
structure most drugs take because an
amorphous state is more efficiently
taken up by the body but the solutions
become crystalline when they evaporate
while in contact with a surface and
studying them while floating in mid-air
there is no pen you're looking at the
earliest color movies ever found the
national media museum in bradford UK
date the film's to 1901 or 1902 and they
were produced by Edward Turner using a
technique in which frames were recorded
on film through red green and blue
filters with the sets of three images
then being projected through similar
filters to recreate the colors this
super stretchy sliver of jelly is so
strong and easily bounces a metal ball
the hydrogel is a mixture of two
polymers that can be stretched 20 times
its original length without breaking the
developer from Harvard University claims
it's so strong you can't even tear it
apart with your hands and they hope to
use this kind of material and
replacement cartilage or as scaffolds
for growing artificial organs tallest
mohawk in the world these prototype GPS
shoes will guide you home no matter
where you are in the world
simply upload your destination via a USB
cable to the GPS located in the heel
then click your heels together to
activate a ring of LED lights in the toe
that point you in the right direction
lifx looks to reinvent the light bulb
controlled by a smartphone it boasts a
variety of features including color
controls timers like a slowly fading
night light music visualization and even
flashing to alert you of social media
notifications finally below for more
information
finally experimental light sculpture is
a BTK college of design student project
involving a jagged surface wall and
animated projected light
[Music]
I'm gonna leave you with the deepest
swimming pool in the world so this is
the 50th episode of mind-blowing weather
you've been with vsauce2 from the
beginning or just recently found out
about this channel through the awesome
videos that Michael is doing over on
Vsauce 1 I just wanted to say that
really appreciate all the great comments
all the stuff you guys send me for bdp
and everything else that makes Vsauce
one of the coolest things on YouTube so
here's to 50 more episodes and as always
thanks for watching also I'm not bald so
I just like hats
[Music]